est ce que vous vous rappelez de
l'émotion que vous avez eue lorsque vous
avez porté votre cartable pour le
premier jour
tac au tac annie cette jeune
entrepreneur sud-africaine a créé des
cartables en plastique recyclé intégrant
un panneau solaire qui se charge pendant
la journée lorsque les enfants marchent
pour aller à l'école et qui se
transforme en une lampe leur permettant
d'étudier le soir car de nombreux
villages d'afrique du sud sont encore
privés d'électricité
nous pensons que beaucoup de problèmes
trouvent leur solution avec l'argent le
pouvoir et surtout en dehors du
continent africain pourtant il y a tant
de valeur a créé par et pour les
communautés en local en proposant cette
solution tato à prouver que le profit
n'est pas une fin en soi mais une
conséquence du bien-être pour toute une
communauté et son impact est multiple
car elle a créé des opportunités
d'emploi pour des femmes peu qualifiées
transformer des quantités brute de
pollution en une ressource sauver des
vies en substituant les lampes à pétrole
dont l'utilisation est extrêmement
dangereuse voire mortelle et il n'a pas
fallu atteinte aux de faire une grande
école de commerce ou d'ingénieurs pour
avoir de l'impact
elle a seulement penser différemment
depuis une trentaine d'années une prise
de conscience collective à encourager la
coopération internationale à agir
les objectifs de développement durable
ont été fixées des programmes de
développement ont été déployés mais
l'aide au développement ne s'est pas
révélée assez efficaces car elles
n'intégrait pas la réalité des personnes
concernées apprenant de ses erreurs
l'aide au développement est devenu la
coopération au développement et la
nuance n'est pas seulement d'ordre
sémantique celle approche qui en est
fortifié fondée sur l'autonomisation des
individus permettant ainsi à chacune et
chacun d'entre nous d'être en capacité
de créer ses propres opportunités
cette logique bottom up également appelé
ascendante consiste à impliquer les
personnes concernées dans la conception
de la solution qui leur est destinée
plutôt que de présupposés ce dont ils
ont besoin sans jamais vraiment répondre
au fond du problème
qui mieux que tu as taux pouvait
comprendre les besoins de sa communauté
et poser un regard nouveau sur ce qui
l'entouré
il est urgent de penser et d'agir
différemment de manière plus agile plus
innovantes qui libère la créativité
humaine en ce sens l'entrepreneuriat est
un levier extraordinairement puissant
pour s'ouvrir au champ des possibles car
il donne les moyens à toutes et à tous
de développer des solutions concrètes
pour relever les grands défis qui nous
incombent femmes et hommes vivront dans
ce même monde mais nous ne partageons
pas la même réalité
nous pouvons sentir la connexion entre
nous mais également la fracture 7,7
milliards d'êtres humains sur cette
planète et seulement la moitié impliqué
car sans les femmes c'est 50% de chances
de s'en sortir que nous éliminons
l'entrepreneuriat pour être efficace
dans son gel de drôles de génération
d'idées ne peut pas seulement être une
question de classe ou d'élite les femmes
disposent d'une force vitale inestimable
elles ont leur mot à dire et leur
solution à offrir
saviez vous que l'afrique est le premier
continent des femmes qui entreprennent
27% y créer une entreprise
c'est le taux le plus important à
l'échelle mondiale elles sont donc
davantage que les hommes à se lancer
dans l'entrepreneuriat
mais elles sont également davantage
confrontés à des obstacles qui ne leur
permet pas de créer et diriger leur
entreprise 35% des femmes entreprennent
par nécessité de survie car elles ont
deux fois moins de chances d'avoir accès
à une opportunité professionnelle dans
le secteur formel
elles ont donc obligé de se battre pour
créer leurs propres opportunités au
risque de ne pas être comptabilisée dans
l'économie est d'être dans des
situations d'insécurité
malheureusement la côte d'ivoire
n'échappe pas à cette réalité et même si
le pays compte parmi les femmes les plus
battante et les plus déterminés que j'ai
eu l'occasion de rencontrer le nombre de
barrières et de frein est tout
simplement trop important
sans garantie d'accès à des réseaux à
des formations à des financements à des
cas de législatives qui favorisent le
respect de leurs droits fondamentaux
l'entrepreneuriat peut également devenir
un secteur d'une grande précarité en
côte d'ivoire
39% des femmes sont analphabètes
réduisant drastiquement leur chance de
trouver un travail et de devenir
économiquement indépendantes globalement
2 % de fonds d'investissement sont
débloqués pour des projets portés par
des femmes et 90% des équipes
d'investissement sont masculines mais
nous pouvons difficilement prendre en
considération ce qui est invisible 1
pour être convaincu nous avons besoin de
preuves de certitudes d'exemple mais que
se passe-t-il lorsque ces exemples se
transforme en mythe comme celui de
penser que l'entrepreneuriat est une
vocation masculine ou encore de penser
que l'entrepreneuriat n'est pas destiné
aux plus défavorisés
est-ce que vous visualisez la vendeuse
d'attiéké en bas de chez vous près de
votre travail peut-être vous la voyez
tous les jours vous échangé un sourire
quelques mots elle vous nourrit alors
pourquoi avons-nous du mal à considérer
cette vendeuse des check les comme une
femme entrepreneur pourquoi pourquoi
retire-t-on le pouvoir d'autonomisation
à celles qui en auraient le plus besoin
car les femmes ne sont pas juste des
maires des soeurs défi elle déborde
d'une énergie d'une intelligence et
d'une détermination sans limite
les femmes sont le plus grand réservoir
de talents inexploités au monde et c'est
ici que j'ai trouvé mon combat libérer
le potentiel entrepreneurial de toutes
les femmes y compris les plus
défavorisés
vers des programmes d'autonomisation de
formation à l'entrepreneuriat et au
leadership adresser toutes les femmes
dans leur diversité dans le respect de
leurs aspirations individuelles et de
leurs conditions de vie car elles ont
toutes le droit de prendre leur destin
en main laissez moi vous conter
l'histoire d'alger qui est une
entrepreneure ivoirienne que nous
accompagnons avec en power
depuis un an elle s'est lancée dans la
transformation de légumes biologiques en
sauce africaine prêtes à la consommation
son objectif son impact et réduire le
temps en cuisine des femmes car ce sont
bien elles qui s'en occupe
réduire le gaspillage alimentaire et
assuré la bonne nutrition de la
population ivoirienne
rien que ça avant sa formation à jen
aurait jamais imaginé être à la tête
d'une entreprise de cinq personnes
vendre ses produits dans les grands
réseaux de distribution abidjanais ni de
lever 2 millions de francs cfa lors
d'une compétition entrepreneuriale mais
pour en arriver là il y aura fallu se
battre
s'opposer à son mari aux idées de sa
communauté au point même de se retrouver
sans foyer car son mari ne comprenait
pas en quoi aller à une formation passer
une journée à apprendre pouvait
rapporter quelques francs cfa
si les femmes avaient les mêmes
opportunités et les mêmes ressources que
les hommes
premièrement le pib mondial augmenterait
de 26%
deuxièmement parce qu'elles sont les
plus grandes victimes des injustices
sociales économiques et politiques les
femmes saisissent davantage les
problématiques du développement et donc
les réponses les plus adaptées
adjé à penser à travers son quotidien de
femme de mère ivoirienne elle aussi est
une actrice du changement en
connaissance de cause pourquoi l'humain
l'être le plus rationnel au monde
n'applique pas sa propre rationalité
toutes les réponses sont devant nous
pourquoi ne saute ou nous pas le pas dès
notre plus jeune âge
femmes et hommes sont formatés à vivre
des expériences de vie différente on les
conditionne socialement à devenir des
jeunes filles soigner aimante et dévouée
appliquée en fait on leur demande de
s'oublier de passer au second plan
tandis que l'on apprend aux garçons être
visionnaire prendre des risques se
dépasser s'imposer ce qui est étonnant
c'est que les qualités présupposés des
hommes sont justement celles près
requises pour être un bon entrepreneur
dans notre imaginaire collectif que ces
stéréotypes soit profondément ancré en
nous ou qu'ils proviennent du regard des
autres
vous rendez vous compte que cette
société
choisi ce pourquoi nous sommes doués ce
pourquoi nous sommes destinées elle
désigne notre caractère nos
comportements notre rapport à notre
corps à l'amour au monde
lorsque j'ai dit à mon père que je
participerai au tedx abidjan et que cela
générait en moi beaucoup de doute quant
à ma capacité et à ma légitimité d'être
devant vous aujourd'hui
il m'a dit de ne pas m'inquiéter que
vous seriez indulgent car je suis une
jeune femme et je sais combien ces mots
étaient bienveillants sincère et plein
d'amour mais je n'ai nul besoin
d'indulgence seulement que vous me
considère y est telle que je suis car il
n'existe pas un type de leadership
un entrepreneur mais des leaders et des
entrepreneurs et l'authenticité et la
clé soyez vrai avec vous même soyez
aligné avec vos valeurs car vos
croyances peuvent autant vous élevez que
vous limitez tout dépend de si elle
forge en vous des perspectives d'avenir
qui vous plaisent et qui vous sont
utiles pour illustrer ce propos
j'aimerais vous raconter une histoire
partons ensemble sur les terre
tanzanienne masai c'est là-bas que tout
a commencé pour moi lorsque j'ai
collaboré avec ces femmes incroyables
sur un projet d'autonomisation qui
portait sur la création de bijoux
artisanaux
pour survivre les femmes masaï ont fait
de ce savoir faire une activité
génératrice de revenus en répondant à
des commandes de boutiques occidentales
la première chose qui m'a interpellé a
été de voir que malgré le nombre de
commandes
les femmes ne sortait pas pour autant de
leur extrême pauvreté et pire encore
leur journée ne faisait que s'allonger
entre tâches domestiques garde des
enfants culture des champs jour de
marché et ceci était dû à deux facteurs
le premier est que les boutiques leur
acheter des bijoux en grande quantité et
à bas coût et de manière très
irrégulière ce qui ne pouvait pas créer
des opportunités pérenne pour ces femmes
la deuxième chose c'est que leurs maris
récupérer systématiquement l'argent
qu'elles gagnent et ne leur permettant
pas de subvenir à leurs besoins et à
ceux de leurs enfants
la deuxième chose qui m'a frappé et est
de constater que ces femmes n'étaient
plus des créatrices
mais une main d'oeuvre bon marché car
ces bijoux dont je vous parle incarne un
savoir faire ancestral transmis de
génération en génération
chaque motif chaque couleur chaque forme
est un choix une intention mais ces
bijoux là n'avaient plus rien d'unique
car la créativité des femmes avaient été
éteintes et leurs ambitions avec
en bref rien de tout ça ne leur
bénéficier nous avons donc réfléchi
ensemble à comment changer leur vie en
prenant en compte leurs aspirations
leur quotidien leur niveau d'éducation
leurs contraintes et basée sur ses
besoins
nous avons d'abord donner des formations
en entrepreneuriat pour leur donner les
bases nécessaires pour créer structurer
et développer leur entreprise
nous avons également mené des ateliers
en leadership qui leur ont permis de
s'organiser prendre confiance en elles
et de formaliser leur rêve celui
d'ouvrir un atelier et une boutique dans
leur village mais pour qu'il y ait un
changement il faut d'abord changer les
mentalités de ceux qui ont verrouillé le
potentiel des femmes à travers des
traditions enracinées sans inclure les
hommes et les chefs de village les
femmes ne pouvaient pas suivre une
formation
c'est pourquoi nous avons dû
sensibiliser les hommes à l'intérêt
économique et social de ce changement et
je peux vous dire que l'impact de leurs
projets a été énorme
ces femmes entrepreneurs sont désormais
capables de vendre leurs créations à
leur juste valeur d'être force de
proposition d'avoir des revenus
constants d'abord des ateliers ou
produire de s'organiser et donc de se
dégager du temps du point de vue de la
communauté
cette réussite a complètement changé la
perception du rôle des femmes réduisant
ainsi les attitudes discriminatoires à
leur égard il aura fallu seulement leur
dire que c'était possible
elles ont fait tout le reste à toutes
les femmes entrepreneures dans cette
salle et au delà j'aimerais vous dire
vos ambitions ne sont jamais trop grande
rêver en grand
vous êtes capable de tout oser
n'attendez pas des autres qu'ils
prennent soin de vous chérissez vous et
surtout faites de vos peurs de vos
doutes et de votre souffrance une force
n'attendons pas des femmes qu'elle
résolve seule l'intégralité de la
problématique
elles ont déjà bien des combats à mener
et ont besoin de vous créons ensemble un
environnement propice à leur
développement
prenons conscience de la discrimination
quotidienne qu'elles subissent changeons
le dialogue sur l'entrepreneuriat pour
qu'il réponde à la réalité et défendons
une approche inclusive
car cette planète notre maison nous
demandent d'agir maintenant arrêtons de
penser par certains pour certains mais
avec tout le monde pour tout le monde et
comme on dit ici on est ensemble
merci
[Applaudissements]